we're going to talk about in this
lecture we're going to dive deep into
the tweet
um
so as you introduced me I'm a data
scientist those are my kids and I'm
currently building acoustic models and
language models I predicted purchases in
my last position and my thesis deals
with online
um classifying online persuasion and I
dealt with a data mining through Twitter
and why Twitter well Twitter is
um a very first ground and a very way to
um to describe all kinds of users all
kind of
um
knowledge and around the world in it's a
very fertile ground from many type types
of research
and there are also many many data sets
um
so if there is a lot of research and
there is a lot of best data sets of
Twitter then why should we even try and
mine new data from Twitter
because usually not every data set fits
not every shoe size fit
and this is why
why I created this tutorial in order to
make you a give you a way to build any
kind of data set that you would like
through Twitter
so where you start
and usually you you start by creating
some kind of a developer account through
Twitter
and you need to apply and fill in all
kind of data and you will use it for
research and and so on and then you
create some cover some kind of an app
some kind of a key and tokens so you can
log into the Twitter API and and get
um and and connect to the the Twitter
data stream and to collect your data
and once you get your key and credential
you supposed to generate them and keep
them it's only yours it's some kind of a
credit card you don't want to share them
because you don't want to any other uh
other people to use your credential and
and twitch from for you in your name and
do some some kind of a unproper use for
your uh with your credential and your
account so you need to keep that safe
very similar to the way you keep your uh
your credit card information
uh and what do you use those Paradise
gl4 you use them in order to log in and
to the API
and there is a package in in Python
that's called twippy and you just use
those credential of the keys and secret
keys in order to log in your to you
through your account to the API and get
that from the data from there
um and after that what do you do
well you install the the the twippy
package to in order to log into the
account funders and Json panels is a
data frame in order to to create a
to aggregate all all the data to parse
it into some kind of a nice table
um and Json
um is the format of the Tweet itself
so
usually when you're logging to the API
key you just use some kind of a query or
create some kind of a filter
and whether it's without media without
a any
um any pictures with pictures what kind
of
um uh what kind of a query you want to
to search for and then you you collect
your tweets
um the the data for format for that uh
is Json and also there are all kind of
limitation
to the API and that you cannot just
stream and and get a
constant data from from the Twitter API
you need to put in some kind of a
timeout
um in your in your code so it's supposed
to have like 15 minutes for every
um for about every four a thousand
tweets you need to make your uh your
code rests uh or or else it will just
reach a time out and crash
um so the original
um
to wait in Twitter contain only 140
characters
and now it contains a 280 characters so
um
the in the data structure itself there
is the the former
um text which only contains one for 140
characters and the three dots that you
can see here I don't know if you can see
them
okay
and the extended to it is the the form
to it
um so when you want to uh um to get
tweets you should choose the the extent
which method instead of the text one
because then you will just get a the
text which is cut
and and if you will go to adopt instead
of the full text
so
um I don't know if you use Twitter some
I didn't use Twitter before I started
researching it so this is kind of a
thread from today
um no actually a few days ago
so
um
what you can see in Twitter you have you
have users you have the user name the
user nickname you have tweet and
retweets you have mentions you have
users you have dates and sometimes Emoji
you have the text hashtags
you you're apply to other people you
have likes and URLs and images
and this is uh some how it's some kind
of a tweet we look like
and when you go to a user page
and you will have their name this tree
name their followers their following
when did they join a Twitter their likes
and tweets
so you have a lot of data points that
you can collect and and do stuff with
them
so as you can see it it's this image
really represents the way at which we
look the way you you see the the tweets
you see the details on the page and what
it looks underneath
so
this is the way some tweet will look
underneath this is the metadata
this is some kind of a
um Json you can see all kind of tweets
repetitive and you can see what kind of
links repeat it in
and this is just some kind of a tweet
and you need to parse it because you
will not want you to work with it you
cannot plot it you cannot aggregate it
you can actually just count the way it
looks like that
so
um
as I said before you can you have the
text and you have the full text
but indeed this example you can see more
repetitive than just the two times
so the text itself can be actually hide
in in the Json of the tweet and you need
to check to to actually actually search
it in order to collect it
so you do want the twitch mode to be
extended and in order to collect the
full uh the full text
but it's not really enough because it
can hide in all kinds of different
places in the metadata of the tweets
so in order to just collect the text it
will look something like that you can
you will search it if it's in in one
place if it's nothing there do it then
you will search in another place all of
these lines of code is only to collect
just a sweet that just the text itself
for the tweets
and you can already read all kind of
different data you can
retrieve the Tweet ID and when it was
created and the source maybe it's a
quoted a tweet and maybe you want to see
how many likes it has how many weeks
and you want to receive dimensions and
the hashtags and all kind of entities
that are mentioning in this the the
Tweet itself
um
you want to see maybe the interaction
between two users one user replies to
another
um in reply to another tweet to another
user and to a screen name
and you want maybe to to receive and to
to collect the user data itself their
screen name they they their ID and there
are how many followers they have
um how many
um how many other how many they follow
and how many there what what are their
favorite counts their status counts and
when was it created
foreign
data
some some
um some sandwich has the the
location data some some don't
and
when you're dying done with retrieving
sometimes
encoding your data when you're receiving
it will create all kinds of sorts of
that of of garbage actually
so
the there is some Sometimes some kind of
a tricky key and
with the encoding
um it sometimes it caused because of the
Emojis we're using texts
so we need to deal with those emojis
when we collect the data itself because
other
otherwise the data will just will look
like
unreadable for humans
and so we're reaching to dealing with
Emojis
so
there are all kind of uh emojis packages
in Python and there are these packages
called emojis that is just
um compare with the encoding to the
Emoji itself and the Unicode
um
but then it's it will look a little bit
messy when you're using that that
specific uh
um package
um
another package
is a very interesting one it's called
emoji
deepmoji and what it does it's actually
use
[Music]
um
and deep learning in order to
to see which similar emojis are in a
closing meaning to the emojis that are
used
so for example
um
if you'll give it some kind of a one
emoji it will generate other emojis that
are similar to the specific emojis that
it's
um that it's giving
which is very interesting package but
again it's not good for our use we want
something that can collect the Emojis
and just translate them to some kind of
a dictionary for like their use
um so
this is a great deep Moji is a great
package but we sometimes
um simple is better
and then there is demoji and what that
package do is actually what we need to
collect all kind of emojis and just
create some kind of a dictionary to
which uh tweet with which emojis were in
our text and just collect them to a
dictionary for later use if we want to
understand what it is they talked about
in the Tweet itself
um it's very very easy to use and very
very nice implementation
um and what's after that well
after you collect all your data you can
start by imagine it if you have your
location
um to it you can just plot it on
so you can view Trends Maybe by location
if you use all kind of correct if you
use a specific queries you can plot them
on a map
um by by their location not all user not
all to it will have location it depends
on the privacy and preferences of the
user themselves
um
when you're not aware and all your data
points appear in the map and
maybe you want to to know who talks
about what
so when we're talking about Trends and
people and we're talking about
influencers maybe we want to see how
they connect who are the main players
who are uh how they they talk to each
other who follows who and who quotes who
which a which tweet
and you want to see their Connection by
the users themselves to connect and plot
a
users that to reply to one another to
that mention one another
and a new social network analysis
and to see how how the main players are
connected
um and this is very very interesting
field in in data science and social
network analysis and graph Theory and
see how they are plotted together
and after you see who are the players in
in our domain and how they are uploaded
on the map maybe you want to know how
they feel about it
you see the sentiment analysis of the
tweets itself using NLP methods uh to
see not only what you're talking about
it is what your opinion what's their
position on a specific topic are there
Pro or against a specific topic maybe
it's a controversial topic
um
and
um this is another field of the way we
can plot and understand and come to
understanding of that environment in
Twitter
and and use all of the Twitter the the
data that is collected from Twitter and
to in order to understand the world
world in the specific domain in a
specific topic
um
and that's it for my talk
I am
is there any questions
thank you for this
sorry thank you for this this talk
[Music]
um
any questions questions
are welcome
I how does Twitter limits rates of
tweets you download I think it just
reached a timeout yeah I see the
question
um so when we're you're gonna I I don't
really know how they do that that I'm
guessing it's like the amount of
requests they get so they limit the
amount of the requests you're getting
and when I tried it
um
more than
I I wrote it down in the specific slide
but it was 404
000 for 15 minutes every 15 minutes uh
for a specific
um
like credentials just give you a time
out and you cannot request for more
all right
thanks
um we still have room for more questions
thank you
so I was actually worried that
um the code itself is from a is a few
years old and I was actually worried
that uh it might something it has
changed and with all the changes that
are in Twitter and I actually checked it
out today and the work the code works
fine
and you can get a data it's also
available in my GitHub and you can just
ping me in LinkedIn there is also links
over there for my GitHub there is a the
entire tutorials there and with
notebooks that you can just
run them use your own code NCR but use
the use the the notebooks